so as of this recording we don't yet
know the winner of the 2020 presidential
election
but unfortunately we can now say with
complete certainty that this
is a country that is screwed whether
trump wins or loses for a long period of
time now i know some of you won't like
this commentary
the votes have been cast there's no more
votes to cast they need to be counted
me saying this now won't change anything
of course
if joe biden becomes president the
country is
able to possibly start reorienting in
the right direction joe biden has paths
to victory
and donald trump has paths to victory it
would be huge for joe biden to become
president we can start to repair global
relationships
we can start to be a little bit less of
a global laughingstock
but almost 67 million people have
already voted for donald trump
about 5 million more people have voted
for donald trump this year
than in 2016. win or lose that is a
recipe for a destroyed
country we have to realize that when we
see
coronavirus economy race protests
these are the top issues and trump's not
polling well
in them that doesn't mean that
your average trumpist actually connects
their vote
to what is happening in their state and
says oh
i will then not vote for trump because i
think he's not doing
well on these issues pandemic running
rampant in my state
because our governor is buddy buddy with
trump and they're ignoring guidelines
and opening everything and having huge
events so the virus spreads and hurts
the economy
yeah i do disapprove of that but vote
for joe biden no but
no way i'm voting for donald trump again
win or lose we have not 60 million
but 67 million trumpists who live in
this country
who will continue to live here no matter
who wins the presidential election
my dad has written recently in spanish
about how to understand trumpists
because truly
how do you understand millions more
votes for trump
in the midst of one of the worst
performances in the world on the
pandemic
it doesn't make sense if you are
rational and thinking empirically
the answer as my dad is written is
magical or mythical thinking among his
supporters
trump supporters see themselves at being
as being at war
against the left against democrats
against the media
against scientists against atheists
against communists and marxists and all
of that stuff
they see themselves as at war they also
idealize
violence and these ideas of courage
and risk taking things by force
imposing their opinions because they are
better
and because america is first as they say
so when you understand the mindset when
you're at war
a normal way of interacting with the
world and others
evaporates and you justify as we've seen
actual militaries justify all over the
world
you justify absurd and immoral behavior
in that situation lying is completely
valid
if you're at war i mean come on guys
it's a war lies lies are no big deal
we're at war here
and so when they say things like
the virus isn't that serious we wonder
are they in denial um do they not
understand
no no you know they they are accepting
that
listen old folks immigrants stuck at the
border with the virus
weak people with comorbidities they're
gonna have to die we are essentially
culling the weak and some of us will die
as well they know some of their people
are also going to die
but it's worth it to win the war which
in their mind
is we must support trump and we must
defend trump at all costs no matter what
those costs are and my dad wrote
it's just like the war approach of we're
gonna take some casualties
but it's worth it because we're going to
win the war it's not just wishful
thinking
because wishful thinking is more
individualistic
this is really a mythical thinking it's
a cultish thinking
which is really more of a group
psychology element it's more of a social
force
and each trump cultist sees themselves
as individual agents recruited by the
cause
to push their values and talking points
with any weapon they can
and those weapons include straight up
lies
spreading fake news going out without a
mask
casting a vote for trump even if he
screwed up the pandemic
they're in love with their traditional
sort of
fascistic authoritarian values these are
authoritarians
they are sort of fighting their
stalingrad against the abnormal
as they see it the weak as they see it
and they believe
many of them that god is on their side
everything that seems
despicable to other people who are
involved in what should be a democratic
process
it's different when they are already at
war
they are operating under the logic of
war we are operating under the logic
of anti-authoritarianism and democracy
so whether biden wins or not this
problem i've outlined
doesn't go away and what we need to
understand is that
confronting what i just described with
empiricism
argumentation rationality
facts it doesn't account for the reality
that they are in a cultish mythical
magical thinking space they're thinking
of
the myth of this is a war it will never
reach them to say but look at these
facts you understand the facts so how do
we interrupt it
i don't have any any idea let's first
figure out who won the presidency
this is not an election that should be
this close but again because of these
people
this election should be 99 to 1 in favor
of biden
based on trump's actions based on
trump's authoritarianism but that's not
how his supporters even think about the
world
the fact that people vote for trump is
in and of itself stunning in a normal
country
um even with a sort of
white nationalist identitarian
nation hyper-nationalistic streak
someone like trump wouldn't get more
than you know being generous
30 of the vote and it would probably be
more in the teens
here donald trump got nearly 70 million
votes
near nearly 70 million votes so i'm
getting ahead of myself
because i've said after the election we
will address the problem of
trumpism first let's figure out
who the next president is going to be